so relieving curve and the discourse on
method this is a class at work in in
modern philosophy is really standing at
the very beginning of modernity we're
all what we call late modern or
postmodern there's different words for
it which means that you know a lot of
times the laughs that a lot of things
have changed since it's not a dick art
but we we draw some sort of distinction
between you know the Medieval and
Renaissance and Reformation period and
all the things that are going on with
that who's very interested things and
the Dark Ages by the way we're not
actually as dark as people make them out
that's that's a misnomer later on but
there is something really distinct
happening with modernity and you can see
that in what's going on a big hearts
discourse you can see it what's going on
with what he's doing today so I want to
tell you a few things about this believe
it or not this was a popular work
meaning not only that a lot of people
like to read it at that time it was a
pretty good seller it was a work in
which Descartes thought that he was
talking to a more general audience and I
put written in French the rest of the
current works for the most part except
for letters that he wrote the people are
replacing their language laughs why that
universally exactly if you were educated
at that time you knew Latin so why would
somebody put a book in French because
you don't have left which means that
you're probably not scholar this book
was for non specialist this book was to
try to explain what he was up to to
everybody else
and it was actually appended to a couple
other books that he wrote which were
more focused on astronomical or menial
meteorological we would
you know whether type of stuff and
physical issues and not a lot of people
read that stuff but a lot of people
still do read the discourse and in
French it's kind of really good spot and
this guy in English this translation not
too bad it's one of the beginning points
of modern philosophy why what's you know
think back to your like your history
classes or maybe you know bring in
things from your literature classes that
you've had or other social studies what
makes us different from medieval people
or from people in the Renaissance other
than having you know technology plastic
things like that
what sort of things changed yeah yeah
one of the things that happen well
there's there's more to know libraries
got bigger yeah
the Environment Agency okay yeah
I said that's part of the expanding of
human value semana what does that
experiment value in fact then they have
ever heard in stones and everything like
that was like do we know if there's
still slavery in some aspects of the
world
yeah even all the way up themselves you
know civil war profiteer in this country
so the value of just okay I see what
you're saying so recognition of like the
universal value of human society little
niche what do you mean by that
it's not like if this guy here's the
farmers so he's gonna bring the grain to
the you know the market on this day you
don't have yeah I could we can change
from job to job much more easily
yeah I'd said that that's about right we
also have more social mobility times
these are all fairly important
developments and they a lot of them
intersect with each other if you look at
it over time the notion that each person
matters that kind of you know that fits
in with well future person matters that
maybe they should get to decide what
they're gonna do for a living bill those
things fit in with each other greater
reliance on reason over to my heart is
the guy who we call the rationalist
he has a great faith in the capacity of
reason to to get things done and yes
well these are important developments
and Descartes is in some way
contributing
and one way you contribute to something
is by embodying it yourself
so if I want for this is an analogy
right I'm not saying it's exactly what
he's doing if I want you to take this
material seriously I do joke around a
bit sometimes but I want you to take
this material seriously I have to show
you that I take it seriously right
otherwise what's the point you doing
this isn't your profession this is an
intro class that you're stuck in because
it's a required class so if I want to
convey to you that there's some value
here I had better be somebody who not
only tells you that there's value and
not only like you know shows it to you
but it actually seems to care about it
myself
doesn't that make sense the heart is
doing something like that the capacity
for reason than the capacity for
thinking for one's own self
and breaking with all sorts of
traditions all sorts of you know well
it's just always been this way kind of
thinking and views on things so that's
her oh my god what we're giving here's a
narrative narrative is a story right so
big heart is sitting down and telling
you and he's being a little bit
deceptive he's sitting down telling you
well none of you have to do it or think
this way but here's what the way it
worked out for me that's the mode in
which he presents it obviously he wants
you to think his way he thinks that
better approaching things his way than
other ways did you get that sense at
least sometimes when he's saying I don't
impose this on anybody else he's being a
little bit disingenuous but what he was
telling you about is the education that
he had and Descartes was pretty
privileged he had a good education
which was not you know you know
personally widespread at the time people
were somewhat better educated than we
want to take them as being in Medieval
Renaissance Reformation times and that
the early modern times because we have
somewhat backwards pictures of that but
he was actually sort of in the cream of
the crop so if his education was worth
anything presumably he would have stuck
with it that experience he tells you
about yeah I'd buy one here and one
there here's what I experienced here's
why I was doing it and then he carries
out this very bold experiment part of
which we're gonna look at today and then
the fault of which we're looking at next
class and this experiment is where the
real meat of his philosophy is so think
about what he's doing is sort of like
stripping away the stuff that's already
there and starting anew so you know
you've experienced this when you're
writing a paper sometimes you're you're
sitting there you guys don't actually
write on paper all right movies the
typewriter you're typing on the computer
right sometimes do you have to actually
like just totally clear your head start
a new document and say I'm gonna make a
new beginning does that work for you
yeah sometimes that's what's needed
that's what the current is trying to do
with the human mind and with
philosophers and with knowledge in
general so that's why we look at it as
this was great innovator that's why
you're still reading him today because
he did this experiment and the
experiment seems to have at least in
some respects paid off so let's start at
the start and we're supposed to work our
way through it there's there's a few
things that before we get I do want to
so in part two you get something very
important rules of methods and we're
going to look at those fairly carefully
I'm going to part three to get something
that he calls the provisional morality
morality is like you know your your
standards of right and wrong good and
bad how you want to behave what does a
provisional mean you guys heard that
term before if you have a provisional
government you guys remember that term
from history class with the only Russian
Revolution and there's the provisional
government No yeah exactly
yeah so until you get something better
something is provisional like let's say
it's at the beginning of the semester I
kill over ten comes with credit class
right god forbid but yeah they got to
get somebody to fill that slot right
away and so one of the other philosophy
people fills in for you and they say I'm
going to be your teacher provisionally
until we can find somebody full-time to
take over you know for dr. Sadler that's
you know just an expedient something
that you make do time being so Descartes
says you can't just like to say well we
don't know anything for certain so
anybody gets to do whatever they want
that's probably not the best thing to do
you need some way of guiding your life
when you're when you're trying to rework
your life and rework your mind so that
you're not going to totally screw up the
life that you've got we only get one of
them so that's the provisional morality
let's start out with the very first
sentence he's got this great piece of
rhetoric he says the most widely shared
thing in the world is good sense for
everyone thinks he's so well provided
with it that even those who are the most
difficult to satisfy and everything else
do not usually desire to have
good sense of than they have so he's
kind of flattering the reader
everybody's smart in their own way
what's the evidence for this nobody
really seems to want to be smarter than
they are they want to know work no more
information but they think that they're
good at judging Thanks now just they
can't really believe this record now why
don't you think he really believes us so
if he thinks he's smarter than us in
that respect a lot actually
he he presents it as if well here's my
method and that's how I got to where I
yeah yeah if you just follow my method
you'll you'll be just as smart as I am I
don't have any advantage over you other
than having a bath but does he really
believe that about about every everybody
we all have just as much good sense
common sense we could call do you
believe that that everybody has the same
amount of common sense yeah leave
everybody any ability you had but they
may not actually that's an important
distinction isn't it that's very much
like hansoms will you know you know the
capacity was made after using it yeah
and then sometimes we blame people we
said well you should have known that
it's common sense I'm never getting that
a lot of kid because I'm going to do a
lot of dumb things and that was my dance
main response you should have known that
you know but it seems like common sense
takes some acquisitions so hold on to
that but he he goes on and he says what
we call good sense of reason is
naturally equal at all people and thus
the diversity of our opinions he's
trying to explain why do we disagree
about that so if it's almost common
sense the diversity of our payments does
not arrive because some people are more
reasonable than others but only because
we conduct our fall out according to
different
we travel on different roads and we
don't consider the same things it's not
enough to have a good mind this is
straight to your point about using it
the main thing is to apply it well the
greatest minds are capable the greatest
license as well as the greatest virtues
and those who proceed very slowly if
they always stay on the right Road are
capable of advancing a great deal
further than those with Russia long long
way for this so what's going on here is
talking about this first of all we have
you know there was a there's a bunch of
memes that are floating around out there
or they talk about less you know major
innovations and technology it's stuff
like that again we don't think about the
cell phone we we call people with this
more often and that we text people
particularly your generation and what
else do we do with these things we look
things up take pictures videos to write
and play games and do social networking
right and some people get kind of here
if they do or they look at they're like
you know you know we've spent all this
brainpower on you know creating these
these these amazing devices and people
just want to like play games with them
well you know people won't play games
with them because games are fun and they
see that as part of their you know good
part of their life you know the current
probably would it would have been a
became that so the question is what are
we doing with this great technology
thinking
we're endowed with by nature do we use
it the way we want to or do we we apply
it to all sorts of other things what
will allow us to apply it well is some
sort of method yeah we have the right we
have the wrong method we're gonna screw
things up right what if you have the
right method then it's surefire you're
going to get everything right so the key
thing is to figure out what the right
method is what the right assumptions are
then how do you want to work with this
this is a distinctively modern idea the
idea that we could just come up with a
method and then it doesn't depend on
what kind of person you are it doesn't
depend on your level of your capacities
you just got to have the method and
everything is going to fall into place
everything can be reduced to technique
if you just have the right technique
then everything is is going to work out
the way you want so he says a little bit
further on he's talking about his own
education he says my design here is not
to teach the method which everyone
should follow in order to reason well
but just to reveal the way which I tried
to conduct my own reason those who take
it upon themselves to get precepts must
consider themselves more skillful than
those to whom they give them if they're
missing the slightest thing they're
culpable but since I attend this work
only as a history or if you prefer a
fable in which among some examples which
you can imitate you all find some others
which you may not have reason to follow
I hope it will be useful to some people
without harming anyone and everyone
find my frankness agreeable so again
he's engaging in some telling you about
what his project is again he's being a
little bit disingenuous does he really
mean to say that I only intend this as a
story I'm not telling you how to mind
I'm only telling you about my experience
no he means for this to be general he
means to offer you a method but he is
telling you about how he got there and
this might be something that you could
relate to along the way he says I was
nourished on literature from my time of
my from the time of my childhood what
does it mean by literature there he
doesn't mean what we tend to mean you go
into farms Noble or what else we got
around here or wolf stores borders yeah
they went bankrupt a lot than that
they're out of bankruptcy now take those
there you go it's tough to be a
bookstore competing with the Amazon go
to literature what kind of stuff are you
gonna find okay so it's the stuff from
earlier time periods
you'll be nice if it was just that that
qualifier cuz they're gonna be closer
but they carbines and we do have a
contemporary you gotta go to a special
section for that yeah generally
classical ready classical writing okay
that's actually close to what Descartes
started that's yeah but don't we usually
mean things like novels short stories
poetry would you find it a history book
in literature we can't split those apart
right philosophy has got its own section
as on section sociology all these sorts
of things now in the ancient period and
in the early modern period in all the
periods in between what they meant when
they said literature was something more
general like what you guys are talking
about older stuff classics could be
history could be you know teaching you
how to speak well could be speeches that
people were actually given yeah so
during that time they didn't read like
classic Greek
Iliad Odyssey yeah you know it's part of
the way that you would become educated
and grammar was by actually reading
literature the idea was you can't become
a good writer without reading we try to
teach it separately and we have like
little snippets of text then we say
you're gonna have your comp class then
you have your literature class and it's
separate things but the way that they
thought about it was we learn your rules
of grammar and now you're going to
actually learn how to apply them I
analyzed tacks and in those grammar
classes quite often the teachers would
tell you about the meaning of the text
so they might be analyzing Aristotle's
politics you know well they better know
something about political theory if
they're going to do that right so
literature was a broader thing the carts
that he was he was nourished on mature
people persuaded me through literature
one could acquire a clear and assured
understanding of everything is flowing
now think about this sometimes people
will say I just you just have to study
the great laws and that'll improve your
mind and everything will become clear
and for us the great books include the
modern period so they might include date
right yes much more modern that
Descartes yeah how do you like gone to a
bookstore
maybe used bookstores are better for
this because you can get the stuff a lot
cheaper and you said I can improve
myself I'm going to buy myself
you know or you went to the library
through the veteran Street I'm gonna get
myself some classic literature and I'm
going to improve my mind maybe read over
the course of the summer maybe you guys
actually just have reading this and they
told me you're gonna repeat these things
up to the summer
now did everything become totally clear
to you after reading say the Iliad I
mean some things that you know who
killed petropolis Hector right does that
help you with your ordinary life or
figuring out how to write their papers
or you know who you should date or in a
halo sort of things there might be some
books that would actually be conducive
to figuring actually you got a date and
it won't be the Iliad and you know when
you think about this that's not the way
great books work Descartes is is making
a point here he's saying as soon as I
completed that entire course of study I
changed my opinion completely I found
myself and burdened by so many doubts of
errors it seemed to me had gained
nothing by trying to instruct myself
other than the fact that I did creasing
Lee discovered my own ignorance but I
had gone to the best schools so instead
of you know the vegetables you have
imagine if we're are this were this guy
to be doing today Harvard are some other
Ivy League school generally the way that
we look at things this is this actually
make my dispense some people who watch
this but I'll say the people that I've
met from Harvard or Yale or or other
schools when I've gone to conferences
they've impressed me no more no less
than people from uncle's talents seems
to be fairly uniformly distributed
initiative those sorts of things the
kinds of things that really matter they
have higher test scores at Harvard but
that doesn't actually necessarily mean
anything
and as far as we know education takes
place in that kind of haphazard way here
in the United States it's hard to
demonstrate that's happening better at
Harvard but Descartes went to places
like that and he says you know what did
I actually get out of these these things
that I'm studying and he breaks it down
by my discipline so he says
studying languages the studying language
is good
yeah can you walk another language
that's pretty handy what he means is
they actually studying Greek and Latin
so that he can read ancient texts in the
original but if you could read ancient
texts in the original you find that
there's a lot more to them than you you
get in the translation where okay so
languages history raises the mind as you
read it with discretion helps inform
your judgment while sometimes you say
you know those who don't study history
are doomed to repeat it but that's not
all history can teach you hopefully when
you take your history classes you get
something out of it other than just
facts and figures you get a better sense
of human beings right it says reading
the great books is like a conversation
with the best inkling of past centuries
eloquence poetry those things attracted
him then he talks about mathematics and
the current thinks that mathematics is
different than the other disciplines
we'll see why in a moment
philosophy what is philosophy teach you
a way of speaking plausibly at all
matters and making oneself admired by
people who are less scholarly I think
sometimes we have that idea of the
philosopher even today in the the
meaning of life it was one of these Mel
Brooks movies he actually calls
philosophers [ __ ] artists and what
do they mean by that well you know
philosophers know how to talk in such a
way as they they snow people they
they're they're great with words they
get people to think that they're doing
something important what really they're
not and you know there's always some
philosophers in any given time
we're doing precisely yeah you know I've
been countered quite a few and think
Eric seems to think that's what his
professor that sounds right this is a
guy who's going to be writing philosophy
so presumably he thinks there's more to
it than just what they're doing theology
what is theology it's like study of you
know religious truths
good for getting that jurisprudence
medicine the other Sciences bringing
honor and riches to those who who
cultivate them take hurt by the way got
degrees in jurisprudence law and
medicine so he had studied for quite a
while so he starts looking at what did I
actually get out of my education now
imagine that you're in the same sort of
condition you go to marys you guys are
at the beginning of your education here
at Marist but maybe you could do this
with with high school think back for
those four years you spent there what
did you we actually get out of it that
you could take with you that you can be
absolutely certain about as far as
knowledge goes nothing I hope there was
nothing some things hopefully dick hurt
doesn't seem never to walk a lot of he
wants to know what can you put on the
table that's a bit more intangible I
think there's some value to that you
don't get the impression from Descartes
that any sort of you know well the
general kind of approach to things he's
not gonna say yeah that's that's exactly
what I'm looking for he wants to know
what do you actually know so even looks
at you know what do you I get out of
reading ancient well it's like traveling
traveling is good and this is like
traveling back to ancient periods so you
know there's something there but fables
make us imagine totally impossible
events as possible so we really you know
for studying literature literature
literature
fiction we start to get a skewed view in
the world we think that impossible the
impossible things are possible it's all
you did was read Harry Potter all day
long
you know you'd think that magic exists
right now that we're all you know it was
like big some sort of big conspiracy to
hide it from us muggles and something
like that and you never coherent
worldview but it would be a skewed right
you wouldn't want to rely on that if
you're just reading Greek mythology all
the time you know comes to dating
I better pray to to Aphrodite find a
good mate you know desire at them and
you know if I want to screw around on my
mate it's probably ok because it got to
do that all the time you know this is
the sort of complaint that Kurt is
making about that even the most faithful
histories if they neither changed nor
increase the importance of things to
make them more worth reading what is
left in them is not to pick the truth
those who regulate their habits by the
examples in who I from these histories
are bound to engage an extravagant see
sense like Don Quixote remember the
story of Don Quixote reads too many
romances and thinks he's a knight and
goes along he's like having delusions he
thinks windmills or Giants and so he's
like you know hitting them with his
Lance and then they like pick him up in
the air and smack him on the ground he
thinks that's a giant hitting it at the
clock that's the way they current thinks
we're going to be able to read too many
stories eloquent some poetry read
written poetry says I like those but
those are gifts given to the land rather
than the fruits of study those who
actually have reason on their side can
convince us much more better than they
can convince us more fully than somebody
who has got a degree say of
communications as good
the truth will always win out they got
those mathematics he says I found the
mathematics especially delightful
because the certainty and clarity of its
reasoning but I did not yet notice it's
real use and that's going to come with
the method what about other things
writings dealing with morality those are
like suburban magnificent palaces built
on nothing with Sam beautiful awesome
nice talky-talk but really when you
start probing into them they fall apart
what about theology you know he said
it's good for gaming heaven that's not
nothing right he says I revered our
theology but having learned that the
road there is no less open to the most
ignorance is to the most learning so you
know anybody go to heaven they just act
nice they have the revealed truths which
leave there are beyond our intelligence
I had to put that aside you know
religious people sometimes so you just
take things on faith
the current is willing to say okay let's
take it on faith but now it's no longer
something I'm interested in talking
about so there's good reason then he
says what about philosophy
once I saw had been cultivated for
several centuries by the most excellent
minds which had ever lived in that
nonetheless that was still nothing in it
which was not disputed and which is thus
not still adapt there's the windup
now think about our class right have you
seen all the philosophers who we've
studied agree on anything other than
philosophy is a good thing
so you could be more dick artists you
know there's there's it's been
cultivated by by the at most excellent
minds that ever lived
there's still nothing in it which was
not disputed and which is about not
still in doubt so he says look if these
guys can't figure it out how am I going
to do it I did not have sufficient
presumption to hope to tear better than
the others so I reckon this virtually
false all the ones that were barely
probable this is a part of dick Hurtz
method from those things into doubt if
it's not absolutely certain don't take
it as a starting point don't rest things
up if you can doubt it if you can say
I'm not sure if this is true or not
don't tell people that it actually is
true and don't tell yourself especially
that's you because it might be one of
those things are you're building your
foundation not seeing up and when you
have to put the rest of the house on
it's gonna all fall apart now
there's a problem here - he says what
about the other sciences what does he
mean - like physics we later called
biology chemistry says they all follow
their principles from philosophy now
this is part of why you take an intro
philosophy class whatever you're going
to study if you pursue it to a high
enough level like you're going to do in
your majors you will sooner or later
stray into philosophy and sooner or
later you will borrow like you said some
principles from philosophy as soon as
you start thinking about is this the
right thing to do you're doing ethics
right as soon as you start thinking
about what about is this a fair way of
apportioning good you're doing political
philosophy as soon as you start asking
about reality and appearance you're
starting to do some metaphysics or
perhaps some epistemology
when you say is this witness credible
you're doing some epistemology so if the
philosophy itself is rotten
and unreliable what does it mean about
the principles you're borrowing from it
they're gonna be unreliable too
so you're not gonna be able to make
progress in the other disciplines in
philosophy isn't fixed so what he says
is all right so again I look at my
education I got a great education at
least on paper but I can't I really
can't rely on any of it
what am I going to do so what would you
do yeah that's what he does he says ok I
got to go out and instead of spending
time with books I could actually see the
world so he says I resolved not to look
anymore in any other science except
could be found inside of myself that's
like thinking about you know thinking or
in the great book of the world was a
metaphor
that Augustine came up with the book of
the world and the card is using and
that's a great way to think about things
this entire world out there is like a
massive book that if you're paying
attention to things you're going to
discover lots and lots of interesting
data and details and maybe even learn
some general principles and the process
so I said you know travels around and he
noticed as much diversity among among
human beings as he did among
philosophers so he says I freed myself a
lot of errors you know if you travel
around how many he hasn't like been in
two foreign countries oh good why was it
a benefit to you yeah learn the whole
yeah she was
yeah and so what they card is talking
about is very similar to that you
learned that our single way of looking
at things is not the only way to look at
that other people could be reasonable
they can also be crazy too there could
be crazy people in our culture crazy
people in their culture and insane
people unless you paint it and both of
them probably look kind of similar you
know and you learn not to take so many
assumptions for granted you know that's
good that's being freed of some some
ignorance so he says my grandpa only
freed myself of errors which can an
obfuscator natural life maybe less keep
listening to reason we all do have
reason but we don't listen to it all the
time so he says after I spent a few
years studying this way in the book of
the world one day I resolved to study
myself so you know if there's there's
three things that you can you can study
in this you can start out with books and
scholars where there's fathers people
who know how to read these books one you
know like maybe they've memorized
portions of Aristotle's Nicomachean
ethics well yeah it does get a good the
books are actually right right so he
goes from there to study overall we had
having experiences world and especially
the people and I just like looking at
birds and things with that is studying
people yeah how they think about this
and that Erna then study the self study
the bike so we analyze what am I really
what am i capable of knowing this is
what makes Descartes different from a
lot of other people who spot the world
yeah he thinks that every one of you can
do this you can follow this method of
engagements so he said this this is
going to be a very useful exercise for
me I'm moving into part two now and I'm
actually going to skip ahead a little
bit he's got this metaphor of like you
know having a city when you build the
city well you guys have known this with
group projects right what's the number
one complaint that you guys have about
group projects somebody doesn't do some
of the work right what's the number two
complaint that you could think of when
you do a group project or greedy
exactly quality quality suffers because
you got too many competing voices if you
had enough time maybe you could all get
on the same page and it would be
integrated but oftentimes it's kind of
slapdash put together right and you can
tell by looking at it and it's kind of
good for us instructors because we can
be like okay I recognize this person
here and they did a lot of work I also
recognize this person's work work and
they didn't date a terrible job so it's
easier to grade that way but think about
now in ancient cities or even just think
about the Kip see here right parts up
that gives you that were once very nice
turning the slums roads go off in weird
directions that probably you know all
that well-planned the city planners
every once in a while straighten things
out and
roads wide wider things like this
because there wasn't a single planner
there wasn't a single designer that we
can't from the start if you wanted a
really nice sitting and Descartes says
what you got to do is knock everything
down and rebuild according to one single
plan we'll be off the old yeah that's
exactly what he's saying but putting new
facades on little buildings you know
some people like that you know quaint
rustic old grid look and stuff like that
so that's up to young bees walk down
towers you know a lot of people look at
they're like I don't really think this
is aesthetically pleasing Descartes is
saying the same thing about our ideas
what we want to do is listen for the
doubt comes in we want to begin trim
down and we want to put all this stuff
aside and just turn within and see what
we can come up with on our own that we
can be absolutely sure about the me that
we're going to like deny that all this
stuff exists we're just going to put it
up in suspension for a little while so
he says best thing for me was to
undertake to remove the opinions I had
received up to that point so I can
replace them by better ones warm up
maybe even the same ones after I'd
scrutinize them after I'd looked at them
with reason so the current suggesting
that at least one time in our life we
want to actually take away all of our
old ideas and trying to start over and
he says you got to be kind of careful
with this he says there's there's two
kinds of minds for whom such a
resolution is not suitable there's some
people who think they're smarter than
they are and they can't stop making
hasty judgments whatever does it mean by
that they're always jumping to conclude
it's right there I was drawing in fences
quicker than they should they don't have
the patience to conduct their thoughts
in an orderly way so once they begun to
doubt stuff what happens to them now
they doubt everything they never reach
any sort of conclusion so if you're that
kind of person then they card with not
be for you you know so every once in a
while you get a student is like I rent a
car now I can't believe in anything it
might be the matrix I don't know you
know it was like goes off from there and
you can tell they're really anxious
about that that's exactly the kind of
person using the card it's saying not
just one step at a time
first we're going to doubt things and
then we're gonna try to rebuild don't
like you know go hog-wild with this then
he says there's also those we having
sufficient reason or modesty to judge
and less capable of differentiating
truth or falsehood than others from whom
they can be instructed must content
themselves with following the opinions
of these others rather than searching
for better opinions on your own so if
you really have the off mentally
speaking and you can't follow through
this sort of thing on your own make her
mistake and then let somebody else take
care of it and then you just you know
get the summary from them later on but
does he really think that's the case for
brynee and you know makes it I mean the
vet you made this bar means that you can
actually think for yourself so you could
take on the cartesian project so he
comes up and skip ahead a little bit
know a bit more starts turned to logic
and mathematics the car was very
impressed by all of them who did being
hard for those of you who thought
mathematics are the majority what's
impressed you about math
those other disciplines yeah in depth
and kind of like sure it is they have
one plus one is two yeah there's no way
around that if you get three something
went wrong right we're you know it's
like you accept that it's truly been an
equity program yeah you can actually
prove things in mathematics yes just
about it sometimes we're so the process
of searching for it but we're relatively
confident that we can find it right and
once you grab once you've got the
formula you know that formula is going
to work provided you got things set up
right yeah seems like once you have an
overall sense at all duplicates of that
problem yes you can replicate things
over and over again that's why they can
fly things we call application in
mathematics right you have general
theory now you just apply it and each
application might be the same as all the
other applications when you get down to
it so that's very attractive we can have
certainty as mathematics now you've
started on logic and logic is very
similar to me automatics and it comes up
with these rules but if you actually
want to make progress to harvest
here's what you ought to do first rule
is don't set anything
that you don't clear the Secession of
technical terms clearly know that means
that you can actually explain it to
yourself it's not like we're talking
about back to Plato the person who
actually has a knowledge you can explain
it to another person reasonably this is
sort of like that
if you just have a vague sense that you
know something that's not really knowing
that according to Descartes they
represent it to yourself that's he's not
worried about representing it to another
person he's worried about whether you
can represent it to yourself and say yes
I know this so he says I would avoid
being over hasty or prejudiced there's a
lot of things that we would have to like
get rid of then we think that we know
that we don't really know if we look at
them and I understand nothing by my
judgments beyond what presented it's
also clearly and distinctly to my mind
that I had no occasion to doubt it so
the criteria for this is you're looking
for stuff that you can't doubt right
we're looking for things that you can be
absolutely certain about
second one is to find each problem the
Institute perks so what do we call this
analysis when you analyze something
you're breaking it down into parts right
that's part of what goes of the
analyzing something we do a bit more but
think about the chemical stuff we're
doing a chemical analysis you're
actually breaking down the the compounds
into their constituent parts when so
well it's this amount this amount this
amount of this level so if you think
complicated problems and you break them
down into parts you're probably never
home a lot more success in figuring out
those individual parts each other wrong
let's think about when you get bless you
and you've got a relationship problem
and it's kind of complicated and you get
people sitting in the room talking to
each other and they start arguing with
each other and it looks like everything
is all mixed up together right separate
them out find out from this person what
are your three big things that you're
upset about what are you here three big
things you're sucking them down even
further
you're probably gonna make more progress
that way than just listening to the
babble of them yelling back and forth
right so that's the second part the
third part he says is to conduct
thoughts and orderly but what is that
means that you start with the simplest
stuff and work your way on up don't try
to solve the big problem right off the
bat start with the smaller stuff and
work on that and then once you get those
figure it out start building up higher
what do we call that
synthesis things together right and the
fourth one is 2/4 is to denote keep
track of what he says make my
calculations it's actually enumerations
throughout so completed my review so
general I to be confident or not
admitting everything break it down break
down when he's actually done take notes
keep track of it good idea to do anyway
even if you're not a Cartesian once you
get into the work world keep track of
everything documents everything cuz you
never know when somebody is gonna come
along and tell you didn't do something
right and you want to be able to say
that you did if you actually did analyze
something keep track of it if you put
things together keep track of the way
that you did it maybe it gets screwed up
it helps you later on if you want to go
back and try to fix it doesn't know so
he says you know if you do this sort of
thing you'll be like a mathematician
you'll be able to make progress you'll
be able to have a crucifix and we'll see
how this pans out in part for it and
part five let's go on to part three now
so we've got the rules of method and now
we want to talk about the provisional
morale so if we're going to doubt a lot
of stuff that's gonna be our project to
just sort of say well you know I know
what I learned as a kid and I know
whatever into high school I know I know
what I've learned so far in college but
I'm gonna like put all that stuff aside
until I can be absolutely certain of it
by using this method by building things
up by you know starting with what I
actually do know and then adding to that
you know bit by bit by bit until I do
that I gotta be able to get by in the
world right
do I need to download it my my cereal
needs milk you know probably not a good
idea for more oil in there because you
other you know could maybe it takes that
no you're not going to do that alright
or well I don't know that people don't
like when I go around and insult them
all the time so I'll just give that a
shot as an experiment and see how that
pans out he's not advocating anything
like that without anything goes that so
he says before one starts to rebuild the
lodging where ones live it's not
sufficient just to knock them down you
got to have another place you're living
right think about this in terms of
apartments yeah I'm like telling my
roommates before you tell off your
roommates line up another spot to live
right because otherwise you might be out
of doors and you have a lot of that walk
with you your stuff or in your car so he
says I can't drop a provisional morality
how do you get by for the time and what
is this consistent first is actually
they laws customs this country July
moderates so trouble don't sit by I
don't know that I don't need to pay my
taxes I'm not completely certain about
that one second so I won't pay my taxes
don't don't do anything like that yeah
yes so for the current he was raised a
Roman Catholic really when it comes down
to the cards actual practice he did not
appear to you know this didn't mean like
go to Mass you know or anything like
that just men don't like don't deny
their religion he was probably more of a
deist an actual Christian Davison
somebody who believes that God just like
gets the ball rolling and then sort of
leaves things alone after that and
doesn't believe in you know a
Trinitarian conception I think that's
more of us what all Orthodox traditions
there's a lot of debate about exactly
how but it just wasn't a card I'd tend
to think that a lot of this is kind of
lip service because I mean once you
start to Dallas stuff you could say
stuff like well I think all those
Christians are a bunch of meanies you
know that would get you a lot of trouble
back though probably not so much these
days back that and that to get you
stupid moderate opinions mean you kind
of believe it you got to buy some of
these opinions so trying to find the
middle ground you know so there's
there's that that'll keep you out of a
lot of problems second maximum he says
is to be as constant
and resolute yeah decision so he's got
this great metaphor is you're gonna trap
to the forest you know where you are
start walking in one direction and don't
change that direction because if you
start like you know changing your
direction every so often you're gonna
end up going in circles and then aw
that's of course yeah so be consistent
yeah not only be consistent only be
hyper consistent he says follow the most
doubtful opinions once I'd settled on
them for myself
there's no less constancy than if they'd
been very sure many s got that metaphor
he says since the actions of lightning
often broken overlay you got to make
decisions that certain times you can't
actually like you know go off to your
study and meditate events you have to
decide he says when it's not in our
power to determine the truest opinions
we ought to follow the most probable
ones now if you do it the time to
consider things you want to actually
apply the method but if you if the best
you can have as a probability go with
what's most probable third match so this
is kind of interesting third is to try
to overcome cell rather than the world
try to overcome and wrap myself rather
than fortune and to change my desires
rather than the order of the world and
given the habit of believing there's
nothing which is entirely in our power
except for our thoughts the only thing
that they card things you really have
control over is how you think about
things so if you want to be relatively
happy he's not the first guy to say this
and stoic stuff this too by the way and
you know pushing out further on there's
there's psychological theories and
psychotherapy to say the same
if you want to get by don't try to
change the little world change yourself
you know and if we think about this in
terms of truth if it's hard to get at
truth whose fault is that is that the
world's fault for being deceptive and
you know screwing us around or is it our
fault for not paying attention to what
it is that we need in order to figure
out what's actually true and what's
actually false we can work on ourselves
if you find that your ignorance of
something if you want to know more about
it go to the library right we're looking
up on the Internet probably both is
better and don't start with the first
website right don't just google it and
take that number one thing compare a few
together
all right you have control over that
don't you you don't have control over a
lot of other things so he says there's
one other thing he says to conclude
these moral precepts I invited myself to
drop a review of the various occupations
which people have in this life in order
to make a choice about the best so this
is something I can think you guys have
probably done at one time what kind of
life do you want what is the best kind
of life for you you've chosen your
majors those of you who have majors
right now because you think that is a
good life for you I hope right if you
don't think it's a good life for you
change your major because you know
you've got the opportunity now early on
to do that if you do think it's a good
good fit for you do it and throw
yourself into it so you want to look at
other possibilities though when you do
that don't you because they might fit
you better and you also want to do this
in a broad sense figuring out what's the
good life in general and you do that by
looking at the different ways in which
people
and seeing how those pan out I think you
know a lot of unhappy people don't you
and you know something happy people
think about why those people are
actually happy and why the other people
are unhappy don't do what the unhappy
people are doing do what the happy
people are right is what he'd say so
this is an attempt to make a choice
about the best without wanting to say
anything about the others I thought I
could not do better than continue in the
very occupation I was engaged for decart
being a philosopher was the best life
and not being a philosopher like you
know the kinds that go to the library
and just hang out in the studies and
drink coffee all day and the cafe and
chitter-chatter with each other but the
kind who'd make some actual progress in
philosophy and that thereby in the
sciences Descartes was also very
interested in mathematics and physics
and biology he actually got himself sick
and died if I if I remember the story
array during an experiment taking a dead
carcass and stuffing it with snow he did
this in Sweden which is not a smart
place to do experiments with snow but
why did he do that well because he
thought that the best thing that he
could do was come up with the right
method then apply it that's what he was
doing he was following his life's dream
and if you were going to approach
philosophie des cartes way of doing it
is a very viable way of
yourself so he says yeah I follow the
method which I had prescribed for myself
I had experienced such extreme
contentment once I started using this
method I did not think one could find
anything more sweet and innocent in this
life everyday I discovered through this
method some truths which seem to be
sufficiently important and commonly
unknown other men the satisfaction I
gaff commensal filled my mind that
nothing else affected so he goes on and
he does this the the the very end of the
story that were getting here he does
this for a while and he's making
progress and then after nine years so
he's he has you know his training is as
an undergraduate and the you know
professional student he's gone out of
the world and a puttered around looked
at things attention go on you know one
within the self come up with these
Maxim's come up with the method he's
done this for nine years and he says now
I'm actually going to like try to do the
whole big project I'm going to knock
down all the buildings and down as much
as I possibly can and then rebuild they
act that position he says I find myself
you know a place where I can be sort of
on my own I'm bothered by things and now
I'm going to begin the real project so
that's where we'll leave a lot and
that's where we'll take up next class
and see one get its real project
actually build something